cette intervention a provoqué la colère
de la biélorussie vendredi est la nature
and of sky à la nouvelle pasionaria de
l'opposition biélorusse est apparu lors
d'une réunion au conseil des droits de
l'homme des nations unies
une invitation à l'initiative des
diplomates européens loin d'être du goût
de minsk et de moscou il juge cette
intervention contraires au règlement du
conseil des droits de l'homme et y voit
une forme d'ingérence dans les affaires
internes biélorusse la participation de
tirano sky à la réunion des ministres
des affaires étrangères de l'ue eux et
une ingérence ouvertes dans les affaires
de la biélorussie minsk a porté cette
position à l'attention des diplomates
européens
le flirt des ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'ue eux avec la
représentante autoproclamé de
l'opposition biélorusse et son
invitation à bruxelles pour communiquer
fait partie intégrante d'un scénario d'
ingérence dans les affaires intérieures
de la biélorussie il s'agit d'une
violation directe des normes
fondamentales de la charte des nations
unies et des principes de l'acte final
d'helsinki de la csc eux sous couvert de
préoccupations fictives pour les
citoyens biélorusses
l'union européenne tente en fait de
décider à leur place comment ils doivent
vivre et ce n'est pas la première fois
que l'ue prend parti dans le dossier peu
de temps après les résultats de la
présidentielle le 9 août dernier
angela merkel ou encore emmanuel macro
se sont rapidement rangé du côté des
opposants d'alexandre loukachenko
l'union européenne doit continuer de se
mobiliser aux côtés des centaines de
milliers de biélorusses qui manifestent
pacifiquement pour le respect de leurs
droits de leur liberté et de leur
souveraineté
une nouvelle prise de position et de
potentiel sanction qui irrite le
président biélorusse 1 les pays
européens harcèle la biélorussie nous
pouvons fermer la frontière trop près de
brest et de grodno et après comment les
allemands iron steel en chine
comment les marchandises seront elles
transporté qui peuvent traverser les
frontières dans le sud ou dans le nord
mais si nous concluons un accord avec la
russie et nous y arriverons aucun des
grands dirigeants à la tête des états
européens ne m'arrêtera
l'accueil réservé à cela n'attire and of
sky à ce lundi à bruxelles apparaît aux
yeux de minsk comme une ultime
provocation peu propice à une résolution
de la crise